n'est ce pas
alors je suis né en 1986 j'avais d'abord
imaginé au commencement de ma vie que
j'avais comme qui dirait la baraka
j'étais née juive mais après le pire
carnage de l'histoire de l'humanité mais
ans à travers priori payer pour moi
j'étais mais femme certes mais en france
pays libre en paix pays des lumières des
droits de l'homme comme on nous a appris
à l'école
un joli pays variés verts riches où il
fait bon vivre
j'avais atterri dans une famille aimante
et équilibrée j'avais semblé t-il
décroché le jackpot à la roulette et
hasard du monde et pourtant cette vision
naïve de mon existence a eu tôt fait de
voler en éclat lorsque j'ai vu surgir
dans le vocable de mon entourage un mot
angoissant et terrible la crise tous on
avait la bouche remplir la crise
économique et la crise écologique et à
la crise sociale la crise européenne
la crise du terrorisme la crise des
réfugiés la crise de l'emploi la crise
des 'subprimes' la crise politique à la
crise de la consommation
la crise climatique la crise l'enfant
que j'étais se rendit petit à petit à
l'évidence contrairement à ce que
j'avais cru comprendre au départ ça
serait pas forcément gagner gagner
alors bon je vais voir appliquer la
leçon bons élèves que j'ai fait et j'ai
décidé que 20 les autres c'était pas
tant mon problème je devais veillée
prioritairement sur moi-même capitaliser
sur mes acquis épargné pour m'assurer
une retraite convenable
je ne vais m'épanouir en tant que
contribuable dans mon plan de vue y
faire des études remarquable gagner
beaucoup d'argent pour ne pas être
victime de la crise économique avant une
silhouette parfaite pour cheminer
brillamment vers une immense réussite
sociale et professionnelle trouver un
mari beau jeune drôle riche intelligent
gentil pour assurer mon bonheur coûte
que coûte
seulement voilà je n'avais pas plus tôt
fait de me mettre d'accord avec moi-même
pour attaquer le problème sous cet angle
que je me suis retrouvée confrontée à
une nouvelle crise pernicieuse
paralysante que je n'attendais
certainement pas la crise de ma dénommé
conscience en effet ma jeune conscience
ne parvenait plus à nier cet argument
imparable que si j'avais eu la chance de
naître mois dans un pays en paix
doté d'un esprit fortement
contestataires quai d'une bonne
assurance maladie tandis que mes frères
semblait peu concerné par la notion de
crise des subprimes et de la
consommation mais plus par la crise de
la survie c'était peut-être que j'avais
aussi des devoirs et que j'allais devoir
décider du rôle que je tiendrais dans un
monde qui aurait du sens en mars 2016 je
navigue au coeur de la crise de la
trentaine en pleine crise des réfugiés
ma soeur qui habite en allemagne
m'envoie un sos pour m'indiquer qu'elle
vient de croiser la route c'est un
couple de réfugiés syriens qui faisait
la manche
le couple avait été pris en charge la
veille dans un centre d'accueil
mais ils avaient faim oui il avait le
temps en 2016 en europe dans un pays ami
exemplaire dans sa gestion de la crise
qui les a invités comme 999 mille autres
à prendre refuge sur son sol dans un
centre d'accueil à je vous rassure
le centre avait voulu les nourrir un
bien sûr mais oups avec de la soupe au
porc donc là je vais vous avouer ma
pensée du moment je me suis dit ok je
connais moi-même le niveau global de la
gastronomie allemande et son culte pour
la boxe l'ouest là brad trost la
currywurst bref pour le cochon mais là
ça me semble tout de même un peu fort de
café
j'apprends donc en direct le 10 mars
2016 l'existence d'une nouvelle crise la
crise de l'accueil
je suis chef cuisinière donc autant vous
dire que cette histoire de soupe au
cochon ça m'a légèrement et chauffée à
l'instant même
j'ai eu envie de cuisiner de tout mon
coeur pour tous ces visiteurs contre 1
qui découvre le sol d'un pays étranger
qu'ils n'ont pas toujours choisi pour
réparer ma honte notre honte j'ai eu
envie de réchauffer d'inviter à ma table
dans ma maison dans mon refuge le monde
entier je ne pouvais plus monter cette
idée fixe de la tête j'avais envie de
cuisiner pour eux est de découvrir leur
histoire par le prisme de leur cuisine
la cuisine comme un langage universel
qui rapprocherait les peuples alors je
parle de mon cher me d'idées à mon ami
et chef cuisinière elodie eu et qui me
dit instantanément oui vas-y on le fait
et comme nous croyons toutes les deux en
un monde où l'amour serait plus fort que
les crises et bas nous avons parlé de
nos plans aux personnes que l'on aime et
nous nous sommes ainsi retrouver
rapidement entouré d'une dizaine de
femmes exceptionnelles d'amis autour du
projet le refuge pour le coup le réchaud
pour refuge chaleur optimisme est ainsi
née le but de l'association était de
fédérer de créer du lien à travers la
cuisine entre les populations
accueillante et les populations
accueillies en france et en europe afin
de contribuer à travers le geste de
cuisiner ensemble a changé lourde et là
nos vies basculent et la nouvelle
histoire commence la première mission du
réchaud a eu lieu ici à grande synthe en
août 2016 sur le canda lignières sur le
camp nous avons tout de suite pris
conscience que s'asseoir ensemble
ensemble autour d'une même table pour
partager le repas ne s'était encore
jamais fait c'était c'était un premier
défi de rassembler les gens sur ce lieu
très individualiste où les gens mangent
mal vite et dans leur coin
après quelques jours seulement nous
avons constaté un changement
d'atmosphère sur le camp les gens
étaient plus guère plus attentifs plus
respectueux et nous avons compris
l'importance de ce rendez vous pris
ensemble autour de la
table lors de cette première mission
nous avons eu la joie d'accueillir une
soixantaine de bénévoles venus de
partout en france
ils ont apporté leur énergie ils ont
contribué à ce changement de dynamisme
du site sans le prétexte de la cuisine
la plupart de nos bénévoles n'aurait
jamais mis les pieds sur un camp il
n'aurait jamais rencontré ces hommes
femmes et enfants venus d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui après trois missions
humanitaires
nous avons nous comptabilisons environ
200 personnes qui se sont prêtés au jeu
de la rencontre à travers la cuisine les
gens en ressortent toujours très gai
très ému plein d'histoires et de
sensations nouvelles
et là force est de constater une chose
la rencontre entre deux êtres humains
semblent avoir un pouvoir magique lé
brawl tous et en particulier les idées
préconçues
la table favorise le mouvement de la
rencontre c'est un lieu qui cimente est
un lieu de réunion qui jouent un rôle
fondamental
depuis la nuit des temps dans nos
sociétés d'être sociaux et gourmand au
réchaud nous montons des ateliers de
cuisine sur les sites et lorsque nous
levons la tête nous observons cuisiner
ensemble cuisiner pour se laisser mourir
par ce sont des gestes de confiance
totale on se laisse mourir par l'autre
on s'en remet à l'autre ce sont bien là
les racines de la vie lorsque le réchaud
cuisine pour les populations réfugiées
il faut parfois prouver que nous sommes
dignes de cette confiance il faut les
convaincre qu'ils peuvent goûter et
apprécier des plats qu'ils ne
connaissent pas forcément qu'ils peuvent
nous faire confiance qu on leur veut du
bien sans arrière-pensée gratuitement ce
sont des notions qui leur sont parfois
devenus très étrangère récemment
nous avons amené un public de réfugiés
non professionnels à cuisiner présenter
et servir leurs plats à un public non
prévenu lors d'un festival de musique en
belgique
vous n'imaginez pas comme les gens
étaient bouleversés comme il était fier
donatien un jeune réfugié camerounais
avait préparé un délicieux couscous le
premier jour il est venu vers moi et il
m'a dit tu te rends compte
le monsieur là bas il m'a demandé
comment je l'avais préparé
c'est incroyable c'est notre fierté de
les voir reprendre une place centrale
un rayonnement parce qu'ils sont à leur
place parce qu'on les a aidés à à
relever un défi qui implique tout un
public qu'on leur fait confiance qu'on
les a aidé à regagner de la dignité
la cuisine est un métier d'apprentissage
et de transmission c'est un métier de
gestes et de pédagogie
nous apprenons beaucoup d'eux
certainement beaucoup plus que l'
inverse d'ailleurs car il nous enseigne
chaque matin la résilience la cuisine
des chefs du réchaud est une cuisine en
perpétuelle évolution fait d'histoire de
rencontres de fusion je voudrais vous
parler de ré bar qui était le cuisinier
boulanger sur le corps chaque jour ils
façonnait environ 600 d'âne pour nourrir
les autres réfugiés
florent laden chef étoilé du nord l'a
convié à venir passer une semaine de
stage dans son restaurant gastronomique
à la fin de la semaine ils ont mis
ensemble à la carte du restaurant
denham à la farine de flandre de le
frein coupe et au levain naturel
n'est ce pas la parfaite illustration de
la richesse que comprend l'intégration
et non pas la globalisation
avec elodie nous avons tout de suite
voulu voir les choses en grand parce que
nous aimons les défis et parce que nous
pensons que les chalenge booste la
créativité le dynamisme et l'envié
d'entreprendre
lorsque nous sommes en mission nous
cuisinons entre 200 et 500 repas par
jour c'est considérable pour des gens
qui ne sont pas de la profession rendre
actif acteurs des gens en situation
d'attenté d'assistanat traiter la
plupart du temps au mieux comme des
enfants au pire comme des animaux cela
provoque une reprise de confiance en soi
qui peut aller jusqu'à un changement de
perspective pour l'avenir
ainsi mustapha jeune réfugié kurde
d'irak a décidé qu'il ne voulait plus
partir en angleterre et qu'il était prêt
à rester en france si nous l'aidions
nous avons obtenu ses papiers et il
travaille aujourd'hui comme demi-chef de
partie dans un des restaurants du chef
doublement étoilé akrame benallal à
paris à travers le réchaud nous émettons
le souhait que l'ensemble de la
profession prenne conscience du rôle
qu'elle a joué dans notre changement de
société
notre métier est un métier qui ne peut
se jouer qu'en équipe une équipe est une
micro société que l'on peut choisir de
manager selon un système vertueux ou non
le modèle ancien d'un chef terroriste
doit être révolutionné par la nouvelle
vague des cuisiniers qui doivent
préférer des équipes mixtes respecter la
parité oublier un système militaire pour
favoriser l'ensemble la bienveillance la
co-création et pour aller encore plus
loin
je dirais même que aujourd'hui cuisiner
et manger sont des actes éminemment
politique à la fois sur le plan social
mais aussi sur le plan environnemental
la profession peut et doit faire des
choix
nous traversons actuellement la plus
grave crise écologique que l'histoire
est connue
or nous affirmons nous affirmons que la
crise de l'accueil la crise des réfugiés
sont intrinsèquement liés à cette dite
crise de l'écologie en définissant la dm
du réchaud il nous est paru évident de
promouvoir une cuisine engagé bio local
artisanes et totalement végétarienne
c'est une cuisine nettement moins
énergivore qui ne nuit ni aux humains ni
aux animaux ni à la planète alors c'est
pas toujours évident de faire comprendre
de faire comprendre aux gens que
cuisiner sans viande
peut-être plus plaisant et durable que
de cuisiner du poulet halal certes mais
transgénique est nourrie aux
antibiotiques bayer comme ça n'est pas
non plus toujours évident de faire
comprendre à un public étranger en
situation de grande précarité que si
nous consommions tous différemment le
monde connait trés moins de guerres et
de misère mais nous tenons fermement cet
esprit nous en visons des notions
nouvelles telles que le respect du
produit
le gaspillage alimentaire aussi nous
tenons à travailler avec des produits
issus de la récupération alimentaire
à ce jour l'association a servi dix sept
mille repas revaloriser 3 tonnes
d'invendus qui aurait dû partir à
l'incinération sait pas grand chose
comparé aux 41,3 tonnes d'invendus qui
partent à la poubelle
à chaque seconde dans le monde selon un
dernier rapport de l'ademe mais c'est un
début nous concernant la route sera
longue
nous l'espérons et nous le déplorons la
mission du réchaud c'est aussi d'être
témoin actif de l'accueil à travers
l'europe et de porter une parole scène
est optimiste à travers les goûts et les
saveurs qu'elle défend eh bien figurez
vous ce dont nous sommes témoins ont
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est de
l'hospitalité à fait merveilleuse des
citoyens belges et français oui nous
sommes rassurés de voir que globalement
la société civile est prête à agir et à
prendre en charge le rôle d'un
gouvernement immobile malades et aliénés
alors je ne vous cache pas qu'il ya
certains matins un peu plus durs que
d'autres où la colère prend le pas sur
la confiance et où l' envie de tout
casser et de déconstruire le monde pour
mieux le sauver me prend à la gorge
c'est sans doute la crise existentielle
qui me court après mais alors
j'entends la voix de mon père qui court
un peu plus vite que la voix de ma
petite existence au plus profond de
toutes les crises de la vie il n'a de
cesse de répéter grand optimiste qu'il
est il y a toujours des solutions
si tu penses que c'est désespéré que tu
dois continuer à chercher et tuent les
découvrira inch'allah
[Applaudissements]